about reductions
great um
at least not yet yeah if it goes all
right you can
consider clapping at the end um
yeah so it's uh just wonderful to be
here presenting at this workshop i
really enjoyed hearing people's new work
and ideas and things
um so i'm going to tell you about
reductions as alex said and uh the
primary aim of this talk
is to maybe try to demystify a little
bit
of some of these ideas to take some of
the magic out of these ideas if they
seem sort of unapproachable
and um maybe the reason for this is
because there's this sort of folklore in
complexity theory that average case
reductions in particular are really
challenging and so we learned this sort
of from the beginning and i remember
taking complexity courses and being told
like all right average case reductions
you don't want to go there i mean
there's been this 11 stuff that's really
nice but we haven't made a whole lot of
progress since then and so um
the primary maybe aim of this talk is to
convince you that we should be
optimistic about this direction in
general
um all right
um
so uh yeah with that said it'll be a
little bit tutorial in nature so feel
free to interrupt with some quick
question i might have forgotten to
explain something some notation whatever
don't hesitate to just ask
all right so this is joint work with um
matt brennan and as uh
many of you know
matt suddenly passed away earlier this
year
in his last year of his phd he was going
to be a miller fellow here in berkeley
he was going to be here in the program
um
he was truly brilliant he was
extraordinarily generous kind and just
full of joy
and uh um in light of that it's um
especially nice to uh tell you about
some of his ideas and to revisit the
countless hours of uh discussion we had
on these topics
all right so
the basic question that we're motivated
by and that pretty much everybody in
this whole semester program is motivated
by is
when can i and when can i not solve some
statistical problem of interest and the
particular uh reason that one might not
be able to that we're interested in is
because it's computationally challenging
we don't have enough computational
resource
many many problems and we've heard about
some of them and we'll hear about many
more and even some of you have your own
favorite problem that you're holding
close to your heart that that we don't
know about
um and so we have all these different
problems and they uh all seem to exhibit
some curious and interesting phenomena
which we've seen a lot of and you're all
familiar with
which is that the complexity of
recovering the signal can often be the
um determining factor relative to the
statistical challenge
not only that but there's some very
interesting interplay between the
statistical challenge and the
computational resource that we have if
you have more computation you need a
statistical resource vice versa
so we want to understand all this
but it's a bit overwhelming with so many
problems
and so one might ask well what would it
mean what would it even mean to say that
a set of problems each have a hard
regime for the same reason what would it
mean to sort of clarify this picture to
some degree
and complexity theory tells us um give
us the suggestion well if we had some
problem some simple problem
but explained fully ideally all of the
computational statistical trade-offs and
a variety of problems
this would be
at least
partially satisfactory
progress on this question it would give
us some insight
so that's sort of the aim um we don't
explain every problem under the sun but
that's kind of where we're trying to get
this direction
now um
what this figure indicates with these
arrows is that this single problem at
the actually this pool pointer the
single problem
indicates oh it's magic right um it's a
new toy um all right so yeah the single
problem explains maybe
what's going on in all these other
problems um but complexity theory tells
us that we should be potentially
dreaming much bigger
as has been done
over the decades in complexity theory in
a variety of arenas
and so we might
aim for strong equivalences between
problems we might aim for completeness
classes and so forth and
if all goes well and we all work very
hard then maybe we can
add a complexity class to the
544
complexity classes
on the complexity zoo okay so that's
maybe some broader context but for now
we're a little bit less ambitious than
this school
all right so we want to do average case
reductions as the title says and we're
going to consider a particular notion of
average case reduction this is basically
the notion
that was advocated for by likam well in
the 80s
and as i mentioned and as you've seen in
luka trevison's boot camp talk there are
other notions especially levins that's
proved very useful in other contexts but
for statistics problems it's natural to
look for statistician
account
special i guess here in berkeley so all
right so here's what the notion of
reduction we consider is we would like a
polynomial time algorithm
a
and we would like to take as input an
instance of either
the null hypothesis pure noise for some
problem or h1 which is noise plus signal
of this is your sort of starting problem
and you'd like to map it
to some other problem p prime
where
the algorithm a has no idea whether
you're observing pure noise or signal
plus noise and in either case it does
the right thing so in other case it maps
the pure noise to the pure noise under p
prime and it maps the signal plus noise
to the sigma plus noise then rp prime
why is this such a good thing well if
somebody
oh i should have emphasized
the way in which this mapping is done is
in
sort of the criterion for success is
that it's mapping
to negligible error and total variation
so what this means is that the output is
indistinguishable from the true
distribution that defines the target
problem
okay and so this little of one here
indicates the total variation between
the output of your map and the thing
that you're trying to map to p prime
is little of one and total variation
okay so why is this good well
if somebody claims to have some
algorithm that solves the target problem
then that's a delightful situation for
you who wishes to solve the source
problem
because now if you're given some
instance of the source problem you don't
know which one well you map to the
target problem
the algorithm solves the target problem
and you thereby solve the source problem
if the algorithm runs in polynomial time
and the claimed sorry yeah the algorithm
runs in polynomial time and the
reduction runs in polynomial time and
their composition is an algorithm for
the source problem that runs in
polynomial times
all right now why total variation the
reason is that it transfers the type 1
plus type 2 error
of this algorithm here
to the new algorithm for the source
problem
okay
um
yeah okay so those are reductions there
there have been a fair number of
reductions um of the slaver over the
last decade roughly
um
apologies if i've missed your your paper
here please email me and let me know i
prefer not to miss people's papers so i
won't be i won't take it personally yeah
please email me if i forgot your paper
um but i want to highlight three papers
in particular
that were you know have been very
influential on how we think about things
so the first one here is
of uh philippe an audience and uh
um
i guess
the shoe here is yaming so we have lots
of audience numbers maybe hong the wu
here is somewhere on zoom so how you
hung if you're there um so anyway i'll
sort of describe how how these uh papers
of influence are thinking and the aim
with uh sort of everything here is to
almost go from scratch fairly quickly
admittedly but
none of the ideas should really seem
like they come from nowhere so
hopefully i can give that context as we
go
but the high level is that one has some
statistical problem it has some
phenomena and the the thing that i think
really shocked everyone and why this
really this first paper philippe really
got everybody excited is because well
this this thing isn't happening in
isolation you can understand what's
happening in sparse pca by looking at a
totally different problem that's been
well studied planted clique and that's a
pretty deep insight
okay so there have been
also a great deal of works talking about
restricted classes of algorithms and
again this is a very incomplete list of
papers my apologies if i've forgotten
your paper here i've left it out i mean
i know i've left out many but if you
want yours added again email me
um
but
yeah so so uh
the the point i want to make is that the
analysis of problems under restricted
classes of algorithms is
complementary in nature to reductions um
and so
why is that well if you do a reduction
between some root problem here and a
target problem
now
there is benefit to analyzing the root
problem under restricted classes of
algorithms
and
if you know for instance one shows
hardness
based on restricted costs of algorithms
let's say now so s lower bound or low
degree concluding that the root problem
is hard
well
one concludes that the target problem is
hard and if there are reductions to many
problems one concludes that all of those
are inappropriate regimes right so
obviously um
reductions kind of amplify the power of
the restricted classes of algorithms
approach yes
are you saying that the group column is
actually hard
uh for an unrestricted algorithm
partner is saying that
for each one of those limited type of
algorithms the reduction shows that
hardness president
um so that's a good question um the
claim that i'm going to make here it's a
little bit delicate because the
reduction might not for instance be a
literary polynomial
however um
all of these are are
all restricted class of algorithms are
proxies for a certain amount of
computational power so whether your
polynomial is a proxy for fundamental
time algorithm
and so you would want to conclude that
you know if the root problem is is hard
these are all giving evidence for it not
being solved in polynomial let's say or
requiring you know to to the end time or
whatever
um and so then one concludes if the root
problem can't be solved in polytime then
neither can these right
but it doesn't mean
okay
so taking answers it doesn't mean that
these reductions are going to imply that
if i have hardness with respect to some
restrictive class of
algorithm this formally constitutes a
hardness with respect to the same
restrictive class of algorithms that's
right so formally no um it would depend
on the situation uh
but with that said if you
then produced a polytime algorithm here
so you thought about sort of the
contradiction that would then violate
your your restricted classes of
algorithms being uh so if you had a
polytechnic algorithm here you would get
a polytime algorithm for the root
problem and you would therefore conclude
for example that the low degree
prediction is wrong
okay so
you can
hopefully that's clear all right so um
we'll just quickly sort of maybe
elaborate a bit on this connection
between
uh first of all classes and reductions
so you know obviously reductions are
future proof the reduction is just there
it connects the problems and if we have
some new better class of algorithms then
we can analyze the root problem uh
against those as well and
include things for the target problems
as we've just discussed
okay
um
and uh
yeah i mean okay this is maybe just sort
of a restatement um
yes maybe yeah i won't dwell on this
point um
except for uh
you know it might be more subtle maybe
i'll mention aside from just polynomial
time or not um so for instance uh in
alex's paper showing that a planet
submatrix or planet dense subgraph is
hard for recovery
is really interesting because well it's
interesting in its own right but it also
has additional implications because uh
we have some reductions that are based
on recovery being hard for the source
problem and so then one immediately
concludes
even stronger statement about the target
problems from their results so they
really do kind of go hand in hand and
play well together
okay so reductions are what we're
talking about that's what we want to do
um the sort of demoralizing thing about
reductions uh that we were faced with
was that the vast majority of them
relate problems
that look like
some submatrix signal
plus noise
with
planted clique
uh you know superficially these look
kind of the same and so uh if you're
sort of ambitious about doing reductions
to a wide variety of problems
um
unclear uh
if this can be overcome in this
challenge
okay so you know we're extremely
motivated to understand can we map from
planet clique
to a variety of problems with
very different structures than planetary
very different from planet submatrix
plus independent noise
so this is the diagram of reductions
from uh
our paper from last year and so there
are a lot of problems here um many of
these problems are problems that various
people in the audience have thought
about a lot and have
really achieved a good amount of
understanding
um
an example of a problem here would be
robust sparse linear regression
and i don't think anybody can claim that
robust parcel linear regression sort of
looks like
and it looks like a completely different
problem and so
um sort of the surprise for us really
was that it's even possible to relate so
many problems to this basic kind of
vanilla looking problem
clinically now as we'll see and this is
maybe the thing i want to convey from
the technical side in this talk is that
these relationships are surprisingly
simple they're
really you can think of them as all of
these problems as being linearly related
in some way
linear meaning linear transformation
so this is a really simple connection
between problems
um
now
before i get there i'll say a few more
words in a second
there are these source problems so one
of them is uh i'll go back here one of
them is
apartheid hypergraph planet gleek so
this isn't actually exactly the normal
planted clip that you're familiar with
it's a variant
here are some other ones that are a
little bit more similar to the standard
planically here's bipartite planet gliac
here's a k-partite version of planet
clique that i'll describe in a little
bit
and you can combine these various uh
variants of planets okay part bipartite
planet click the main point is that
k-part hypergraph planet gleek is the
strongest assumption assuming that
that's hard is the strongest assumption
and implies all of these others and so
there is just one source problem that
underlies all of these problems
another remark is that one can sort of
unify these different
versions of planet clique under a single
version that's called secret leakage
planet clique in our paper
and in a nutshell and i'll describe it a
bit but in a nutshell it just assumes a
different prior over the clique position
so instead of being uniform it's
something else
okay so there's two key ideas that the
this is the aim to convey uh one of them
is if one squints at all these problems
squints uh you know fairly intensely but
but nevertheless just the squints these
problems um then these problems are
related via linear transformations
and uh
these transformations i think you know
matt really didn't didn't want to make
it seem trivial and so he didn't want to
say that they're linearly related and so
he he came up with this nice name called
bernoulli rotations
um
but when it comes down to it um
it's it's really after various massaging
and squinting one gets uh that these are
linearly related and so that's the main
technical thing i'm gonna sort of
explain in great detail going step by
step by step building up from a very
simple scenario up to various uh of
these reductions
um and then the second one is this thing
i mentioned with the planted clique
assumption actually not being so
convenient and a little bit of a variant
makes a lot of these techniques work
much more easily
we don't know how to make them work with
the vanilla planet click but a tiny
change helps a lot
yes please yes
so maybe you'll get to this um later but
if these were
genuinely linear transformations then it
seems like uh you could pass through
low degree lower bounds sos lower bounds
to step through these reductions so is
there some i don't know does that seem
it seems very possible absolutely yeah
so
yeah it seems absolutely doable in my
opinion but again these things have to
be checked very carefully so you'll
check that these transformations
involve a critical linear part and
various other things that are um are are
here and maybe this is this asterisk of
of if one squints um one requires
various techniques for uh algorithmic
change of measure so changing of
distributions from say bernoulli to
gaussian but others bernoulli to poisson
various other distributional changes um
filling in missing entries and matrices
going from symmetric matrices or tensors
to asymmetric ones and all sorts of
things of this nature which
one would have to do a little bit of
thinking whether one can implement all
of those as low degrees i suspect yes um
but for instance with this change of
measure thing i mean one would have to
do some argument to argue that you know
you can truncate some polynomial and it
doesn't induce too much of a loss
good question yeah
all right
okay so i'm not going to talk at all
actually about all of these uh
these gadgets and tricks these are sort
of probabilistic gadgets very different
in flavor from the sort of gadgets that
people are used to in complexity theory
but i'm not really going to talk about
those
and
the the reason is because um
they're sort of what makes this all look
so fuzzy and murky and i want to
explain how it's actually a fairly clear
picture of what's going on
but if you're interested i'd love to
talk with you about these these tricks
and things because they're important
otherwise
nothing else you know can actually be
made to work
okay so here's the plan uh we're going
to warm up by talking about
gaussianization of bernoullis a
technique called gaussian cloning and
then
a sort of strengthening
called reflection cloning
we'll talk then about bernoulli
rotations which is this linearly
relating thing that i mentioned which is
actually a generalization of reflection
cloning so that's why it's going to be
worth going through this whole sequence
and then we can apply to
a bunch of problems of interest we'll
start with robust sparse mean estimation
we'll
see tensor pca
robust sparse linear regression
and also stochastic block models
i know many of you um
especially and the european side of
things are very interested in stochastic
block models so
i might swap the order between
the sparse linear aggression and
stochastic block models
okay so uh we start with our warm up
here's planted clique as you're all
familiar with we're going to be
considering hypothesis testing
formulations
for everything in this talk i should
have mentioned
but
you know most of what we say works for
transferring estimation problems as well
but yeah hypothesis uh testing
so uh detect is there a click or or no
clique of size k and they're
disregarding your random graph
um you're all familiar with the
thresholds
for us
we care that there is no algorithm known
that succeeds when the clique is smaller
than a rudiment
and there's considerable evidence
for this
via restricted classes of algorithms
including by many of the folks in this
room
all right so it's going to be uh
convenient for us i mentioned the secret
leakage so i'll just quickly mention the
the simplest uh variant of secret
leakage uh panic leak and so secret
leakage is just that you know something
about its position therefore its
position is no longer uniform
okay so here's the particular way we're
going to constrain the position of the
clique
we're going to have a
uh
a partition into k parts so here's each
you know part there's n over k vertices
needs partition
and we have the constraint that there is
one click vertex per partition
okay now if you think about this
you should ask yourself i mean is this a
mild constraint or a severe constraint
on the position of the clique and you
might convince yourself that it's fairly
mild
and the reason is because well if you
just choose k vertices at random the
vast majority of them will live on their
own within one of these partitions
so it's a mild constraint it doesn't
reduce the entropy of the click position
very much
okay so this is the sort of constraint
that is going to be useful
and uh
well the conjecture is that this is such
a mild constraint that it doesn't change
the threshold
for hardness relative to ordinary
clinically
okay
as i said you can generalize this to
think about other priors over the plique
position
and
the natural thing to do is to
analyze where does the threshold occur
based on low degree polynomial
prediction or statistical query and one
can arrive at a prediction
that's for general
distributions rho
which has to do with if you sample two
independent click positions according to
row this is the prior
and then one looks at the
probability mass function
of the cardinality of their intersection
there's a condition on the rate of decay
of that probability mass function okay
and this is unimportant for us
um
in this talk but the point is just that
one can analyze this slightly more
general starting assumption and
you know move on for that
okay so here's again uh there's actually
the warm-up i thought i thought i was
gonna do the one but here's the warm-up
okay so uh for those of you haven't seen
this uh there's some really cute ideas
here and uh
these ones are not are not our ideas so
um
this this problem is by clustering uh as
i mentioned this is uh
it's paper and um
by clustering problem well you have an n
by n matrix and here is planted an
elevated mean so there's a k by k sub
matrix mean lambda and the rest of its
gaussian noise
this is the phase diagram this the easy
hard impossible
diagram
and well they show a reduction from
planted gleek that explains this hard
triangle so i'll just very quickly
explain this reduction
the
hard triangle looks like this
let's first consider
the bottom edge of this triangle okay so
if you look at the bottom edge of this
triangle um
sort of i mean i should have explained
what the axes are here uh assuming
um you uh you paid attention to this
talk yesterday this might be especially
confusing because you should have you
sort of saw this but it looks different
and the reason is because the
parametrization is a bit different
so here lambda the size of the mean is
on the vertical axis
so it scales like n to the minus beta as
we go up the problem gets harder the
signal gets weaker here on the x-axis we
have k to the alpha sorry k is n to the
alpha so alpha gets bigger
this the planted signal gets
bigger and the problem gets easier
you can see that in terms of how these
regions are arranged
all right so yeah so we're going to
start with the bottom of this triangle
we start here
and you know the first thing that you
would uh
ask yourself when you look at such a
diagram is okay what does this actually
mean in terms of the y clustering
problem and so here beta is zero because
we're on the x axis so we put
essentially a constant size elevated
mean
uh in terms of its magnitude and then we
have the size of this
planted submatrix and it's somewhere
between
i guess zero and square root of n
all right because look at this you
should think well this looks a lot like
planet clique and indeed it does
and um
the first uh
step of achieving this bottom of this
triangle
via reduction from planet cleak is just
to map the entries of
planet clique
entry-wise to the appropriate gaussian
right so how does this look like
right because obviously if you know you
started with
this is the planet click phase diagram
and we're just transferring over this
little red strip to this triangle
okay so um
the first thing if you're going to have
such a mapping is
you better map the cleave
which is bernoulli one in other words
all ones
to
the the planet distribution
which is
gaussian with mean lambda and so if we
call this distribution p that means one
maps to a sample from p
it turns out that you want to map zero
to a sample from two q minus p
what is that well let's check
what do we need to check we need to
check that bernoulli half gets mapped
correctly and so bernoulli half gets
mapped to the half-half mixture of two q
minus p and p
which is q
and so indeed this will map all of these
bernoulli half entries out there into q
which is standard gaussian so this
accomplishes the change of measure from
bernoulli to gaussian
excellent now some of you
astute listeners and the observers in
the audience will see that
maybe this isn't
quite satisfactory because 2q minus p
isn't necessarily a valid density
that's true
and that's part of the technical work in
manu is they show that you can truncate
this distribution and get something that
is a valid density and it doesn't affect
the output too much in total variation
okay so um
this paper has two nice ideas actually
the first one is this idea of changing
bernoulli to
gaussian
obviously just to reiterate the reason
why this is non-trivial is because
you have no idea when you're observing
an entry that's one or an entry that's
regularly half
you need to apply a markup kernel or
randomized mapping to get an appropriate
output that actually maps each of these
to each of those right
okay
so
this is this really nice idea and
actually they have another really nice
idea which is
um that they show how to change the size
of the planet structure while
appropriately trading off with the
signal strength and that's in order to
achieve the other
triangle other edge of the triangle and
um it's going to seem fairly simple in
this context but we'll quickly build up
to a much more
uh general version of the same high
level concept
okay so um the idea is that we're
starting down here right so constant
lambda essentially or you know slightly
decaying lambda
and we want to move along this edge of
the triangle
so we need to grow k because we're
moving to the right and we need to
decrease the signal but we can't
decrease it too much obviously if we
were to move at the wrong angle we'd
just not be tight against the algorithms
which is where the screen region is
and this turns out to be this line is
that lambda k squared over n is constant
okay so here's the uh
the sort of reduction that that manu
came up with it's a simple idea and it
turns out to work so what they do is
they start with
two by two blocks so it's four entries
of the matrix
and they average them
okay
what does that do
well we end up with a matrix that's half
the dimensions so it's you know n goes
to n over two
now with high probability you're only
going to get one of the planted entries
in each of your two by two blocks so k
actually stays the same
because you're not decreasing the size
typically so k stays the same here what
happened to lambda well we need to
retain the fact that the variance was
one so we're normalizing
by two
uh
because we're adding up four entries and
so lambda goes to lambda over two we can
check what this does to
scaling so lambda k squared over n
goes to lambda over two
k squared over n over two so indeed it
maintains that constant value and it's
moving along this this trajectory
does this make sense for everyone
okay
turns out that there's a completely
different way of doing this and this
other way is what generalizes in a nice
way okay so we
came up with this way of doing things in
this 2018 paper
um but it's actually based on a very
simple idea um which uh decisions might
call gaussian sample splitting or
gaussian cloning
i think phillipe first told me about
this
a long time ago and i was very excited
to learn about this sort of
almost trivial fact that's surprisingly
useful
so here's the idea
you're given as a
input
to this little mini subroutine a
gaussian with mean lambda okay so lambda
can be
this planted lambda in the problem you
could also think of lambda at zero
doesn't matter
the output is going to be two
independent copies
of a gaussian still with variance one
but lambda has now decreased and you
have to pay something right if you're
gonna have two instead of one you can't
get it for free so the signal strength
decreases a bit
so how does one do this
i mean you already know how to do this
people don't know how to do this this is
a i mean this is actually a little bit
surprising but you know because you're
sort of creating more of something
you're creating more signals somehow
even though the signal went down right
so it's doing something interesting okay
so here's the the way to do this so what
is it the point is the map but the
mapping has to be deterministic is that
are you oblivious to lambda sorry it's
oblivious to lambda it's oblivious to
lambda okay
olivia's lambda perfect yeah otherwise i
can just make some new samples you know
otherwise you can do all sorts of things
yeah yeah exactly yeah that's right
okay so so we're gonna sample a fresh
standard gaussian independently of x
and uh sorry this is a little small
we're gonna
hit this uh pair of gaussians now with
this orthogonal matrix
and uh of course by linearity of
sort of the gaussian and linearity of
applying a linear transformation
you have here
the same matrix times the mean vector
and then the the matrix times
area of standard gaussians
now
this is as i said an orthogonal matrix
we know that isotropic gaussians are
orthogonally invariant and so
this remains
isotropic gaussian
we see what happens here on the mean
vector well just the left column
it's lambda and you have the
normalization one over root two
and so this is
now the output and we're done
okay so this is just orthogonal
invariance of the gaussian distribution
very simple
um
now
there is something that's a bit
conceptually funny here which is that
it's doing sort of the opposite of what
maui did instead of shrinking things
it's like blowing things up but it turns
out to accomplish the the same trade-off
and so we can see that quickly so we
take a single entry here
um
we turn it into four lambda goes to
lambda over two because we went from one
to four instead of one to two like on
the prior slide
k goes from k to two k now because the
planted thing got doubled in
in
size
um
and so we can just check what happens we
have lambda k squared over n here we
have lambda over 2 2 k
squared over 2n
and uh the the k's they're sorry the
factors of 2 cancel and we've indeed
moved along this axis of the triangle
along on this
edge okay
excellent so
any any questions on this by clustering
so this is my own was
manual stuff
very nice
idea so
you know we might
think beyond by clustering well a
natural problem and it's already shown
up today multiple times is a rank 1 sub
matrix so we now have a rank 1 spike
here
and
it's still living in a gaussian
matrix
you might ask was anything changed are
the thresholds different for this
problem does the phase diagram look
different okay so here's the phase
diagram
of by clustering now what's changed here
and this is an example of a rank one
matrix is obviously that some of the
entries are negative
and
this whole easy regime is obtained by
adding up the entire matrix and
comparing to a threshold and so that
trivial algorithm no longer works for
rank 1 sub matrix where some of the
entries in the planted thing are
negative
and indeed the
the phase diagram changes
to
the even for the detection problem
changes for the to the recovery diagram
for by clustering but anyway this is
this is now the the diagram and you know
this bottom edge of the triangle can be
achieved in the same way and we just
need to figure out how to move
from this point which means constant
lambda and root n size planted thing
up up and right so how does one do that
well
obviously we need to increase k
and the signal shouldn't decrease as
much because its slope went down
how can we increase k without losing as
much signal
well let's think about what we did well
we did this cloning by drawing an
independent gaussian z
through all this uh exogenous noise and
we're injecting it into the problem in
order to transform things
if you pause and look at this for a bit
you would say well wait a minute this
whole matrix is full of gaussians
can i just reuse some of these gaussians
like why don't why do i need these
gaussian out there in the world to to
degrade my signal let's just reuse some
of them okay so that's that's what we do
so
um here's this technique it's called
reflection cloning
we start with this uh by clustering so
this is all positive these are all
laminas
as as here on this bottom axis
uh we make two copies of the of the
entire matrix
flip the bottom copy and multiply by
negative one the the entire matrix and
of course the gaussian is uh
gaussian it's symmetric about the origin
red here indicates that it's negative
and uh
you now rescale slightly by root two to
keep the variances one and you add them
and so up here we have the top minus the
bottom over root two and on the bottom
we have top plus bottom over root two
for the for the
entire sort of rectangle
and if we just um
give these original pieces names let's
say x and z
i should have put z i think above above
x then you'll see that it's actually
just the same exact orthogonal
transformation applied to now sub blocks
of the matrix instead of taking this
exogenous noise
okay
okay so now you can repeat this
horizontally and
we now have these negative entries
and positive entries
and it exactly looks now like a rank one
sub matrix but it's not an instance of
by clustering which has everything
positive
so this added freedom of having negative
entries actually allowed us to do
something different
and you can check that well lambda went
to
lambda over 2 and k doubled and n stayed
the same and so
it indeed moved us along the correct
trajectory
okay
please yeah
do you do this on the entire matrix you
split it into two
get this operation being done on the
entire end by a matrix
that's right yes exactly so it's done
simultaneously for
sort of half of the
the entries relative to the other half
at a time yeah
and then it's repeated i should say i
mean this this only doubled things right
so now if you actually want to move
along this edge you have to continue and
you repeat this
okay
take the question in the audience here
yeah
the random entries of the original
matrix
might not be mapped to
uh all random entries in the in the
larger matrix
is there a danger there well at each
okay so at each step the uh the entries
remain independent and gaussian so you
just argue that inductively now what you
can have is that you can have some of
these things colliding this is a little
bit maybe
uh
maybe slightly misleading to just you
know talk about flipping along the
middle here and having all the planted
stuff at the bottom so you can have some
collisions and uh
indeed if you have collisions then um
your planted structure will no longer
stay completely flat like this but it
will stay rank one
and so um one is reducing not to a
completely flat rank one sub matrix but
to
something that's almost flat uh but
still rank one
the norm the norm is preserved of the
planet signal ah
actually
as he says as you know the entire matrix
as a whole is not getting larger it's
just that the the planted the planted
part is being is being expanded that's
right and actually the way that you're
saying that is actually really crucial
so i'll emphasize this what's happening
is that the planted signal is getting
sort of smeared around and it's getting
smeared around in a very particular way
but this notion of sort of smearing
around the planted signal while keeping
this matrix roughly the same size is
important
thank you yeah
okay so uh this is all you know planets
that major
nevertheless uh
looks a lot like sort of planet click
except for not having these negative
entries and um so the next you know
segment i want to say how to generalize
this in a you know significant way to
get to all these other problems uh this
question yeah yeah thanks but are we
also preserving the prior from which the
planted the rank one uh
i mean what what's happening to that
because that's just sort of getting
doubled in size but where one half is
minus the other half
what do you mean by preserving the prior
i mean the because the the support of
the prior is even completely different
right because now you've moved to
something that's i don't know n to the
two thirds size and
has a different signal strength and has
all these negative negative entries as
you
another question maybe this is not what
you're asking another question is can
you invert this so if now
does the reduction actually
given an algorithm that solves rank 1
sub-matrix can it go back and solve the
original byte clustering uh recovery
problem
and uh the answer to that is yes i mean
all of these transformations are you
know very easily invertible and so
you can
go back and figure out what was the
original location of the planets that
matrix even though you moved it all over
the place
okay
good so yeah so we want to get to all
these problems we won't get to maybe all
of them but we'll get to several of them
um okay and the generalization of this
reflection cloning is uh
this bernoulli rotations thing
okay so there's sort of uh
you know maybe one technical portion
that
is actually not uh super hard or
anything but it is maybe just kind of
the
something to think about in terms of how
one might generalize this reflection
cloning
it's this slide so here's uh maybe it's
this and the next but
um
here's an abstraction of what's going on
in reflection cloning
okay so we're starting with as input
a vector the vector has
all bernoulli half entries
except for it has a single entry
that's one
okay and this one is in the i position
and
we call the planted
bernoulli of i distribution just really
halves with a one in the i position
okay now this vector could arise due to
flattenings of matrices or tensors or
whatever but it's just easier to think
about vectors
the output is going to be
a gaussian
with identity covariance
and
mean vector
that's something that you choose
so we have a collection of possible mean
vectors
and uh
if
the input distribution was the planet
bernoulli of i the ith position was one
then the mean vector that you get
is
a i
okay so this is up to the algorithm
designer or the reduction designer is to
choose these
these uh vectors a1 through a n or a
design matrix a
okay so that's what we want and formally
there's some total variation guarantees
here and stuff on the outputs don't
stress about those there is one
important thing though which is this tau
whoops this tau here
is
allowing making essentially making sure
that you don't cheat
what is happening if you think about
data processing inequalities tell you
that you apply some randomized mapping
and you can't take two distributions at
this distance and go further
this is essentially ensuring that that
fact of reality is true so it's
unavoidable
and uh essentially the thing to observe
is just that we're rescaling here by one
over the maximum singular value of your
design matrix where your design matrix
is formed by arranging together these
columns
okay this makes sense because if you
were to for example just rescale the a's
to make them
take things further and further apart
they'd be sort of cheating and so you
have to to normalize
okay um of course the key is choosing
these matrices
these vectors ai is in a smart way in
applications
okay so uh how does this uh reduction
work
so first we just gaussianize this entry
using the mawu distributional map you
now have
a gaussian where
the
mean if your input was kind of bernoulli
with a one in eighth position well you
now have a standard basis vector e i
just a one in the eighth position again
it's you slightly lost some signal
there's a tiny loss there like square
root of log n that's what the c denotes
all right
now
if you want the mean to be a i then the
obvious thing to do is just to hit this
vector with the with the matrix because
it'll just pick out the ai column
okay nothing surprising there
the only annoyance is that this also
messes up the covariance matrix
of of our thing it's no longer isotropic
so you have a a transpose living there
that's a little bit unfortunate
it turns out that this can be corrected
and the way to correct this is just to
add in
an additional gaussian
with the covariance chosen carefully in
order to cancel out the covariance that
that's put here
this makes sense so this is identity
minus the the thing that they got formed
when we re when we scaled by alpha or
sorry by a
and this sort of explains maybe where
the this uh rescaling lambda is coming
about because you need this
covariance matrix to be psd
so lamina had better be big enough to to
suppress that so that that's psd
this makes sense to everybody
right we've
gaussianized the planet bernoulli so it
was all bernoulli halfs and there's a
one gaussianized it hit it with some
matrix that we chose and then corrected
the covariance matrix that's it so very
simple
okay
so we're gonna see a first application
of this and i know i don't have a ton of
time um i might go over just a few
minutes because uh
yeah
i really like to show some of the cool
applications but i won't go too too much
over
maybe just a couple minutes so yeah um
all right so here's robust uh here's
non-robot sparse main estimation
we will estimate a k sparse vector in d
dimensions within some l2 error ideally
as small as possible from n samples
that are all gaussian with mean mu and
isotropic
covariance
but sparse mean estimation just estimate
as far as vector and gaussian noise
it's a statistical limit and
computational limit are both k log d
over gamma squared and there's a very
easy estimator of just thresholding the
empirical mean that achieves this
however
we can consider a robust variant of this
where epsilon fraction of the samples
are
potentially adversarially corrupted
there's a very classical problem it's
arguably sort of the simplest problem in
robust statistics
and what happens if you allow this
epsilon fraction to be corrupted is
there it
suddenly is
a
different computational limit that's off
by a factor of k from the statistical
limit
okay so how does one achieve this well
there's a nice paper of jerry lee and uh
a group at cmu that shows how to achieve
this computational number
uh
using
some complex programming i won't get
into that for us the interesting
question is well why is there this
computational limit
um and so we're going to consider a very
specific instance of robust first mean
estimation so here well
we're going to we're going to sample the
corruptions id from some outlier
distribution
and that we're going to choose a
particular outlier distribution and this
is the outlier distribution suggested by
david nicholas cain and stuart and then
analyzed under the statistical query
model
by these folks and so
sort of they understood what is the hard
instance for robust works i mean that's
the machine and so
uh we were inspired by them and we
thought okay we should probably use this
as our um as our distribution to reduce
two
because it evidently seems to be the
hard one all right so what is this
distribution well the the mu here the
sparse mean vector is just going to be
flat it has value x on support s
the outlier distribution
is
going to be gaussian
and
its mean is also flat on support x on
support s but has value minus y and y is
chosen so the
overall mixture has zero mean
here's a cartoon of the of the data
matrix we have our d dimensions we have
our n data samples
an epsilon fraction of the samples are
corrupted and so an epsilon fraction of
these columns will be red
because those are the ones that
correspond to
to y
so the outlier ones
the rest of them
on support s which s is just the
these coordinates where there is a
signal
those are blue and value x okay so this
is a cartoon of the data matrix um
one of the things i wanted to to convey
and uh i think i'll convey here and also
in a couple of the examples because
it'll be very quick to see
is that looking at these sorts of
cartoons can just uh
really tell you how one should should
carry out these reductions
and so this is this cartoon
we want to reduce from planet clique so
let's start with planet clique here in
each block there's going to be a single
one because we're looking at the secret
leakage you know k-part type version of
planet clique
the reduction is just well apply the
bernoulli rotations to each row in each
of these blocks
and one now gets
a gaussian of some mean where this is
the corresponding column of our design
matrix
right
so now we we have
a gaussian there and its mean is the
column of our design matrix and you do
this everywhere and one gets this matrix
and now we want to just compare it to
our cartoon and that'll inspire us in
choosing the design matrix it'll tell us
can we actually carry out the reduction
okay so we just sort of pattern match
there
we get this should be our you know this
is how our column should look like of
our design matrix it should look like
this what does that mean
well it should have an epsilon fraction
of y's the outliers should have a one
minus epsilon fraction of x
and well it needs to be an approximate
isometry
um and that's due to the signal
degradation that happens in the
bernoulli rotation so we just lose uh
some big factor
okay now
i'll just make a quick kind of abstract
remark which is that
this a being an approximate isometry and
this connects to aaron's question you
can think of these uh all these problems
abstractly is there's some signal and
it's in noise
and what's happening here is we're just
kind of mapping the signal and the noise
and we're preserving the lt norm of the
signal
and and so if you think about some class
of spectral algorithms or something like
this and a problem where those
algorithms are going to be tight against
the algorithmic threshold
these transformations are preserving the
signal strength
so that's that's why this approximate
isometry condition
is entering it's because otherwise
you're just not going to map tight
against algorithms
okay so how in the world do you find
such a matrix
um okay so
just to start let's imagine that epsilon
is half so now we need a
matrix where each row has a half of its
entries
some value and half of its entry some
other value
um and if we go back to our reflection
cloning
we we see that um
actually maybe we have we have uh an
understanding of of how to map to robust
first mean estimation with epsilon's
half if you just repeated this over and
over again you'd completely fill in this
of course it's the transpose of the
prior cartoon i drew but
you would see that you just have
completely filled up the this sort of
strip and with half of its values one
and half of it's always minus one and so
it would exactly be mapping to robust
first mean estimation
okay
um now
probably everybody here recognizes this
as a
dimension to hadamard matrix
and um
kind of the correct way to think about
this reflection clinton construction is
actually is applying a hadamard matrix
and you can do it all in one shot you
don't need to do it iteratively like
this
so
here are some
hadamard matrices
and
you can just kind of visually inspect it
and convince yourself that roughly half
of each row has
value one and half as value minus one
and we all know that hadamard matrices
are orthogonal so it exactly satisfies
this isometry condition
okay so how do our matrices solve the
robust first mean estimation reduction
specifically for epsilon is half so you
might ask okay this is this is good but
nobody's interested in robust estimation
with half of the samples being disturbed
by the adversary so what's going on how
does one generalize this
so this generalization is uh
is
uh
quite elegant and and uh um
yeah it's something i guess that
matt realized just one day kind of out
of the blue
um and i can explain it very quickly is
what's going on in this generalization
so
um
here's a 4x4 headline matrix
and uh it turns out that you can
understand these hadamard matrices in
terms of
the incidence geometry between
planes and points
in an appropriate
vector space over finite field of
appropriate dimension so what do i mean
well
here we have f2
squared so
length two elements of
f2 here on the left we have
hyperplanes and f2 squared
and we're going to fill in a matrix
with certain values depending on whether
the corresponding point is in the
corresponding hyperplane
the one if it is and minus one if it
isn't if you do this then
you can just visually inspect that this
is exactly the bottom three rows of this
head marked matrix
so this gives an alternative way of
constructing hadamard matrices
based on this incidence geometry of
climate field vector spaces
okay good
so far i haven't said anything about how
to generalize beyond epsilon is half
um
but it turns out that if one takes
the cardinality of your field to be r
and one in general looks at f r to the t
this is going to be the column indices
are the points that are the t points in
this vector space and on the left here
one considers
the enumeration of hyperplanes plus all
of their affine shifts the affine shifts
turn out to be critical for
epsilon shrinking
or for our growing
and you fill in the entries one or one
minus r depending on the incidence the
point is in the hyper hyperplane or it
is not
okay so
um
we can see various things immediately
from here namely that if you think about
the given point a given column
and we ask well how many
of the affine hyperplanes is it in
what's obviously in a fraction one over
r because there are shifts of any given
hyperplane and only one of them contains
the point
of food
that's right
yeah so there's hyper planes of code
mentioned one yeah perfect question yeah
that's right but in general you could
consider more complex constructions
pairs of hyper planes quotations bigger
than one etc okay so if we just go back
to our uh zerada what did we want this
matrix a to satisfy
well we wanted it to satisfy that it has
a one minus epsilon fraction of the sum
value and well epsilon is going to be
one over r and
like we saw in the prior slide it
exactly satisfies this proportion
it also turns out that um
this construction gives an approximate
isometry it's not exactly an isometry
but it's very close
and uh it's pretty quick to check just
do the combinatorics of
of this geometry
okay
um okay so unfortunately i want quite a
bit slower than i wanted um i do want to
just show some some pictures here i
guess there are a bunch of good
questions but yeah i really want to show
a few pictures for these reductions
because that gives this flavor of okay
so you just choose this matrix in smart
way
maybe even exactly the one that that i
already described for a bus price mean
estimation and we get reductions to
various other problems just by the the
cartoons of what's going on and someone
can immediately see
at least some of these reductions
okay so tensor pci i won't dwell on
um
but maybe i'll just accept to say that
the same reflection cloning idea based
on hanomar matrices
maps to sort of the canonical
generative model for for tensor pca
where you have some rank one spike
um that's not at all sparse and has
entries that are plus and minus one
okay but i won't say more about this um
okay the nice picture
for uh for those of us who care about
stochastic block models is as follows so
i'm just gonna describe this one briefly
and
um
yeah and then probably we'll stop so
okay so here's a cake community
stochastic block model let's take k is a
little over n
so this is the cartoon of how that looks
there are these
this is
the mean of the adjacency matrix
you know you observe bernoulli's of
course
now of course i i said this at the
beginning but and you observe a
symmetric matrix and no diagonal and
things like this but as i said there are
tricks to
allow you not to stress about this so
it's easier just to think about
i mean we could think about a bipartite
version but the point is it doesn't
matter
okay now the information theoretic
limits here are given in terms of p and
q and k and n
and uh similarly for the algorithmic
threshold and
you've all heard about the custom stigm
threshold which describes where
algorithms fail to succeed
all right so we want to understand if we
can map to something like this
we don't know how to map to something
like this
but we can map to something that looks
uh
very similar in flavor okay so i'll
describe what we're going to map to
imagine that you're trying to recover
the first community
amongst the k communities okay so we
have the first one and then you know the
rest
not too concerned about what's happening
there and we're just going to imagine
that all the edges are kind of spread
around so it's a sort of mean field view
on the rest of the communities
given that you're trying to recover the
first one okay so this is just the
average edge density in
the bottom right of the adjacency matrix
okay so this has the same thresholds and
in general for a detailed discussion on
where these thresholds occur for a
variety of different stochastic block
models i refer you to jim ming
there's a nice paper discussing kind of
a broad class and where the thresholds
occur
so this is what we're going to try to
reduce to
[Music]
now i won't bother with
reparameterization and so on you'll have
to believe me or we can talk about it
later
um what i want to show you is the
reduction so um
we start again with k part bipartite
planet clique
consider a single such partition here
it's a single block in this matrix
there's a single one this is the outer
product of some ei with ej
i'll apply the same design matrix krt
that we got out of the
construction with the
incidence geometry between hyper planes
and points on both sides
what we get is the ice row and the
j throw out our product
pictorially we know that there's a one
over r fraction and a value one minus r
roughly minus r
and ones
that's proportional to this outer
product which when you write it out as r
squared here
minus r minus r one
and
if you remember this is exactly how
on the larger scale our
imbalance to community stochastic block
model look like
so if you kind of plop this down in each
of these blocks
then you genuinely get the the
stochastic block model that i claimed
that we would reduce to
so this is exactly the same
design matrix as worked for robust first
mean
and
estimation
achieves the you know it goes up to the
custom stigma threshold
all right so uh i'm a fair bit over over
time so i won't tell you about robust
first mean estimation sorry robust parts
linear regression even though um it's my
favorite reduction from this paper um
it's a bit unfortunate um
you know i mean unless people really
want but then i'm just going to screw up
the whole schedule for the whole day so
i can't be responsible for that so yeah
we're not doing this um i will say that
maybe the one you know 10 second thing
to say about this is that uh
robust uh sparse linear regression or
mixtures of sparse linear regressions
like very blatantly a supervised
learning problem you're observing pairs
x y
and uh some of these other problems are
unsupervised
and so one of the intriguing things here
is this uh tight link between
unsupervised and supervised problems i'm
sure that that on some levels you know
this link has been observed before i
mentioned this adam ends and he goes
yeah of course you condition on this
thing and you get something so
um
i think people sort of know about this
connection but to make a tight
computational connection between the two
um
um
and uh
yeah i'd love to chat with people about
about this reduction
um some other time
um
and uh
there's many many other reductions in
this paper um i invite you to look at
them and i'm happy very happy to chat
with people about them
maybe just to conclude finally so again
thanks for the 10 minutes over
um
so maybe the high level is kind of
twofold
one is that with all these statistical
problems and they have all these
peculiarities this distribution that
distribution these funny planted
structures
and the general aim is to try to
understand them through simple
combinatorial problems like kind of
cleave or variants of them
um
and maybe the surprise is that all of
these are related and
what is actually a fairly simple way
just linearity
applied to the structure
um
okay so this really is just a
you know
just something to that should increase
our optimism about this general
direction and there's a ridiculous
amount of stuff to do in this general
direction and reductions um and
surrounding stuff and
um
you know very much hope people uh
you know
jump in into the fray
um
so i'll end there thank you
um
quick question about the um the
incidence geometry construction i it's
possible i just missed this but like
is there perhaps like a randomized
construction that's not so coding
theoretic that would
suffice yeah great great question so um
there is a randomized construction
that it works well for
certain of the applications for other
ones it does not
so in particular there are tensor
versions of this matrix construction
where the randomized construct the
obvious randomized construction just
doesn't work at all
if you do still care about this matrix
construction the randomized construction
is in some of the applications almost as
good
but certain things it doesn't do quite
right so for instance it will change the
size of it sorry it'll induce a random
output size community
for instance in the svm
and here it maps to deterministically
sized community
so if you care about those sorts of
distinctions and the problem definition
does the algorithm have to be robust to
not knowing the size of the community
things like this
then these uh based on commentarial
designs are
more effective yeah it's a great
question and there are some alternatives
i have a question if i may
it's a good time
uh i was wondering in the mapping for
the stochastic buffalo did you need the
number of communities to be of the order
square root of n or does that actually
go through if you have very few
communities like five
it doesn't go through for any
constant
number of communities um
but it it's uh
the number of communities is little of
root n so it can be
i i think you want to think of it in our
reduction as any
polynomial and to the alpha for alpha
less than half and greater than zero so
n to the 1 over 100 is fine
in particular so
i don't know where this where this is
exactly but r here
this is 1 over r and so this is
r is the number of communities so we do
need r to be growing a little bit but it
can grow
slowly
so what is kind of the challenge for the
constant
are maybe this is a this is a great
question i think it's a generic
challenge actually for all of these
reductions and so you know one of the
maybe philosophical points that's worth
making about these reductions is that
all of them are between parameterized
problems so there are all these
parameters like signal to noise ratio
parameters but also here number of
communities and things like this and
part of what makes these reductions
possible is that
they all lose just a little bit in the
parameters so typically it's like some
log factor or square root of log or
something so it's not egregious but sort
of nothing is sharp up to constants i
would say and so that's maybe the high
level of why that's challenging
thank you
great okay one more question here
i think
one of your earlier stars you mentioned
that we like to go beyond the low-rank
signature signal plus the independent
noise structure while most of your
examples still fall into that category
so what do what would you think would be
a really nice solution let's say to
other types of problems
okay good yeah so so i guess that's the
yeah that's a question as well all
everything that you're doing is low rank
plus plus as uh sparse as far slow rank
plus noise or something but um i think
it's kind of an eye of the beholder you
make a good point i mean
you know especially in retrospect you
look at these and they're reductions and
you'd say okay well you did reductions
these must not be that different um yeah
i think there's validity to this i think
you know it's uh
one can always look at the next thing
that looks just a little bit more
different than what we've been able to
map to i mean i think personally like a
robust sparse mean estimation
doesn't look like sparse lowering plus
noise or like tensor pca that thing's
not even sparse anymore and there's a
statistical implicational gap you know
so that's one of the interesting things
and there's no sparsity there but it's a
tensor um
yeah maybe what about like uh planted
csps or something i mean this to me
would be a
glorious to connect that to some of this
i mean i don't even know if it's
possible it's unclear
but that would be a good challenge for
people
does the sparse slr stuff naturally
generalize if you have like sparse glm
or the link there's a non-linear link
function but within that you can have it
very good so yeah the question is what
about glm's general link functions um
yeah i think it's one of the most
promising open questions in this
direction we know how to map to some
very weird
not very weird but just not the
canonical version of sparse phase
retrieval for instance
um but for general glms uh yeah we
actually worked on it we have some ideas
but um it's something i'm happy to
discuss yeah
great uh so since we're behind schedule
maybe we should take a break now
there's a lot of room later in there
great so break until 11 10 which is
about 25 minutes um yeah let's think
okay again
[Applause]
we will say bye bye i don't know
and disconnect thank you guys
yes
this is